last nights news from the ABC whale camp
was grim ice floes were threatening to
shatter their camp their spring hunt
depends on the ice and depends on the
ice being safe enough for them to be out
there working to hunt the wheel since
then the hunters have gone silent any
update on an AVC will that's not good if
it becomes too dangerous to have people
out there the can happen in the way that
it normally does suddenly an alert comes
across the VHS ABC has retaken their
campsite and landed a whale on the side
of the high ankle Roger all right thanks
apparently the whale is up to the hall
out point so now they're rigging the
well and it could take a half an hour it
could take three hours you never know
we're headed out on the ice to Arnold
Brower crew um whale it's ABC crew and
they're really experienced crew we don't
want to be later we missed the initial
measurements answer later we work with
them a lot and they're great great crew
to work with any time because you could
always potentially break down on the
trail there's polar bears all out around
here so you don't want to be out there
with that again and fed ever did happen
resonating
it's a blessed day it's a wonderful day
everybody's happy and shouting for joy
you aren't the family and the coil
captain is all psyched up and ready to
come home defeat the community you can
see in as well as some nice and round
and plump this is what they call the
right way
[Music]
boo boo has given up his bear gun for a
hook I'm usually a hooker while they cut
it i hook the hook on the blubber and
then i'll pull on it and then they'll
give them space to cut it and then we
cut it in pieces and we separate it to
shares or just called Ning yep it's a
big thing to me actually I just follow
one my uncle's my grandfather I follow
what they say so it's a pretty big thing
to me